fans of the show know we love bud light
seltzer and you know what we love more
than bud light seltzer when they sponsor
the show they are the presenting sponsor
you know about bud light seltzer it's a
delicious hard seltzer from bud light
with no bud light in it each one is only
100 calories 5 alcohol by volume and
gluten free and now they've got the
perfect flavors for summer with the bud
light seltzer lemonade variety pack and
the brand new bud light seltzer iced tea
variety pack you can try them together
which christian did the other day and
make your ideal alcoholic arnold palmer
with a bud light seltzer ice tea and
lemonade mix pack or dive into the good
vibes of yesteryear with the retro
summer pack and retro summer icicles
there's that cherry limeade that's my
favorite flavors and you know you can
combine there's a peach iced tea and
lemonade you combine those together get
a peach arnold palmer stay tuned to hear
more about bud light seltzer's newest
offerings and a little more about us and
our summer memories later in the show
but now the show
[Music]
this might be a story i love stories
that start that way
why don't you tell me if this is a story
okay a couple years ago i was on a plane
new york to l.a i'm sitting in my seat
first row next to me is a is a guy i
kind of we had just a moment where i had
to get around him and he was like but he
had his hat really low and he seemed
like he just didn't want his space
interrupted and at the end of the flight
we're about to land in la and um the
flight attendant came over to the guy
next to me and she was like
i didn't want to bother you but i just
want to let you know we are we're all
really big fans of yours and he was nice
he was like oh thanks a lot thanks and i
looked at him a little bit longer than i
had out of the corner of my eye
and it was matt damon
matt damon was next to me for six hours
and i had hung out with him a couple of
years earlier for new year's we had like
a new year's eve with friends and i
ended up at his house like late night at
his house but i didn't say anything
because i didn't know if he'd uh what do
you think is it well it's an anecdote i
would say
i would say it's a name drop a double
name drop yeah because you hung out with
him earlier and he mentioned him twice i
would say it's an anecdote more than a
story
a story would be
this would be a braggy story if the
flight attendant then said to you
i worship your work i've seen everything
you've ever done yeah and to him and she
was just like oh i i like this one move
you did i've had that experience too
where i've been around actors like that
people would say oh you're great and
like they go up to that actor and now
i'd be there and they would say
and you too i've seen that happen to you
well let's get into it life could be a
dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short um i'm
your
name droppy host i guess justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
i just dropped my own name can you drop
your own name no unless you're like uh
mr anthony hopkins
i think he might be one of like seven
people who can do it
with me as always is also a named person
christian long i have a name
but i'm not a name
you may one day be a name but now it's
just probably not but maybe you're a
name to some people
listeners by the way don't [ __ ] on
yourself or your name people listen to
the show am i being falsely
modest i don't think it's false because
i don't like when people do that i don't
think it's false i i think it was
sincere but um i'm i'm correcting you
because i'm reminding you that there are
people listening who who like you there
are there are people who know who i am
yeah they know your name that's true
that's true anyway that's the show i
don't
know in all likelihood i will never
achieve matt damon name status
wow but you don't who knows who knows
you know i might get really good at a
sport and compete in the olympics oh boy
you know who knows yeah i know that's i
mean you can safely say that's not gonna
like you're not gonna be in the nba you
think i have a better chance of being
uh like a huge action star like a born
identity kind of
actor
at this point or go to the olympics in
in some random event and compete for the
country and not win a medal well
a couple weeks ago prior to that bob
odenkirk movie being released that movie
which i want to seek on i think it's
nobody you're saying i could be a future
bob odenkor well i'm saying if bob oder
can be an action star that's true it's
pretty likely and and i'm trying to
imagine i've been thinking since we
talked about it the other day what
olympic event you would
excel in do you think have a better
chance of competing in
curling for the united states or being
in expendables
12. it'd be so fun to be in the
expendables those movies are ridiculous
why are we talking about
uh okay sorry um we have a guest today
yes who is matt damon when i think of
matt damon i think of goodwill hunting
it's a classic and i remember watching
it for the first time in the theater
yeah was it 1997 97. well our guest
today is the female lead of that movie
yes our guest is the incredibly talented
actress a very bright funny uh an
acquaintance of mine minnie driver
throughout the course of this
conversation uh we're moving closer to
friendship status yeah she is um that's
exciting it is cool she's always been
like she's always seemed so impressive
to me i know well from them i think that
was my introduction to her was that
movie and she was so charming and
likeable and i mean i loved that
relationship that really and we talk
about it how important that relationship
is to that movie into matt's character
will's journey i had known minnie for a
while as i just said and i never had the
kiss she's one of those people in my
life you know who were like friends of
friends so we'd see each other in groups
but i was so excited to have the
occasion to really dive into that movie
but i she said to me afterwards um that
she had not talked about it ever wow so
you're like breaking that serious yeah
for good hunting yeah so uh i hope
you're excited to hear about goodwill
hunting because we get into it let me
also mention that she has a new podcast
that came out
in march i believe yeah and it's called
mini questions great title great pun
we've got we you know we love a good
pawn here on life is short with justin
um and i did her up an episode of her
show and she is well you're gonna be
about to hear from her so you'll hear
how good she is at talking she's a hell
of a talker
um she is a wicked good time oh my god
she can talk with the best of them toad
she is [ __ ] awesome and uh
she's
really funny so uh and has what a career
to talk about and like you said doing a
lot of uh exciting things now so we get
into all of it uh right now we're gonna
just so let's let us get into it please
here she is
minnie driver
[Music]
[Music]
we came to london so my kid could go to
school
and
we've been here since
september
i'm just go i'm going to go back uh end
of next week oh well for the first time
in so then over a year
yeah really yeah wow yeah
i know we meant to come for four months
and we stayed for almost a year how how
was that on your kid what was i mean
he was the driving force yeah he was
sick of he was so sick of zoom school
and
all the attending like
he
he literally he was the funniest person
and when um obviously apart from you and
when um
he was showing me like they were doing
p.e
via zoom like in his room
and i mean i went in and like he was
just looking at me like what the [ __ ] is
this and why are you paying money for me
to do this
how old is he he's 12 like going on 35.
i bet yeah
well are you struck because you're
very funny and you're very
uh is it safe to say
brash body uh
oh
i mean
i think it's just normal but i think
other people might call it british
okay i like how you said that you said
that in a very refined way but i i don't
you don't strike me as somebody who
filters a lot which i love i mean i love
parents who
you know you got to filter obviously
some things but you you strike me as
somebody who is
it has exposed him to um funny
interesting things he must be like
uh very advanced i would imagine
he is a really interesting kid i mean
single mom
with a son and
i was interested in him from the very
first moment i met him and he's just
proved them worthy of all curiosity and
has such an extraordinary he has such an
extraordinary world view and is
constantly now
correcting me in
um
things that his generation are learning
as wrote
that
we are having to kind of remind
ourselves to speak whether that's
pronouns whether that's talking about
gender talking about you know i made the
mistake the other day of coming oh
i hope you end up with a nice girl and
he was like you don't know that oh no no
no no no i may end up with a a guy or
they or a mix or an it like you don't
even know the pronoun i'm gonna end up
with mom so just stop it
first of all i like that your son is
vincent pastore from uh but he is he
sounds like that's exactly right he
sounds like a bookie from new jersey hey
mom listen yeah first of all you
listen i told you
i'm a he is
i'm a vedas pansexual
you know who knows what i'm gonna be
next week by the way he can tell you he
can tell you everything about
everything
about the conversation around gender
around sexuality it's so it's like they
learned this language and it made
complete sense to them because they've
never really gotten their teeth into
anything else and now it's just fluid
and that's what's interesting and that's
why he that's a lot i mean it's part of
what he teaches me but i love how he
speaks his mind and i love that he
he's just decided
to go to the school that i went to that
my sister went to that my mother went to
which was
you know we were pretty much we were
like 75 percent self-sufficient when i
went to school you know we'd melt the
cows make the cheese what's really the
bread and then do double physics oh oh
my god wait wait you do that at home so
you're you i didn't know you grew up on
a far on a farm then well it was kind of
it was like this amazing community it's
this it was the first co-educational
school in great britain in like 1893 the
guy
john badly just had a different idea
about education
and
we were raised being
outside i think as much as we were
inside and what's interesting is that
academically
people
um
amazing people when dan day lewis went
there and um amongst many other
interesting cool
writers actors statesman politicians
and
it's a it just shows you it's kind of
like that if you're working the left
brain right brain you actually a lot
more goes in what's the name of this no
it's called b dales it's in hampshire in
england is this anything like the
waldorf school is it the same well
funnily enough rudolph steiner
was great friends with or took a lot of
his ideas from
badly who was the founder of our school
you know we weren't knitting faceless
dolls
we were
but we definitely were collecting the
sheep's wool
and
washing it and spinning it and dying it
and then weaving with it well i think
that's more hardcore than the doll thing
and by the way shots fired on waldorf
school
um
wait uh first of all and i also love
that you call him dan day lewis i've
never heard that's the that's
you must know did you do you know you
must know him a bit i do
very oddly and we are not we are not
related by blood but we we we were
related by marriage his
his like second cousin was married to my
mom's sister for many many years and
then they got divorced and because he
went to my school
there was this weird connection so and i
was completely in love with him at you
know the age of 13
14 he used to play in these um old
alumni football matches and i used to go
and stand on the sidelines literally
like in the driving rain and the wind
i'd just be standing there like with my
ponytail just soaking waiting for it to
stop so i could walk back to the chain
it was with him and be like i really
want to be an actress he must have loved
that that must have been a very
seductive move you know what it's super
super yeah he was so nice to me he was
so kind and nice and wow charming
supportive and whenever i see him
through these weird years every sort of
three or four years or so um we talk
about school it's amazing to not be
intimidated by a guy like that i would
be i think when you love someone
like i didn't have posters on my wall
with anyone except him really
i loved him i saw him
he was doing hamlet at the national
theater and he had this extraordinary
episode his father had died and he saw
the ghost of his father on stage and he
he couldn't continue but i saw him on
stage and was i was mesmerized i've
never seen anything
anything like it minnie did you see that
actual performance
yeah you did oh
wow
i've cause of course i mean i've heard
that's one of those stories that that
you just those greats
when you when you're too great almost
i think it's also maybe it's settling
into greatness yeah yeah
i think that
because clearly
everything i don't i i don't know of a
better actor like for me just for me
personally that is my that is my
favorite jam but i could never
i could never be
a method actor like i you know a couple
times i tried i would just sort of
giggle when i'd keep an accent going in
between takes or not want to ask what
was for lunch and hope that it was you
know sausages i know well that's the
thing i recently uh did something where
uh we
the actress and i couldn't stop laughing
during the time it was but it wasn't
like the in the fun way where it's you
think oh
we'll just get through this and this
will be a fun outtake it was there were
so many funny elements that
um and we were in trouble we were
getting in trouble for it which which
only added to the it was like being in
church and not being able to laugh in
church it was so this and the stakes
were high it was we could not
stop and i
i thought like in that moment well i'll
never
you know sometimes i have these moments
and i don't mean this in a self-effacing
way i don't mean this to be like
self-deprecating but like i sometimes
have moments where i think i could never
be
you know they're great like dicaprio
daniel day-lewis those guys i could
never
do that and i i i'm now imagining
if i were so lucky to do a scene with
him the the fear
of laughing i mean i'm sure that would
prevent me from then cracking up but but
can you imagine you sound like you might
be prone to that as well
definitely but i'm also
um
i'm also
fascinated by
amazing actors and watching them and i
mean there are movies i've been in when
i would show up like in in goodwill
hunting when they shot the park scene
the park bench scene with robin williams
and matt damon i've actually i've never
seen it
i'm kidding i'm kidding it's one of my
favorites and i can't wait to talk about
it i haven't seen that movie no wait
tell me please minnie i went to watch
because
because there's real there's real
mastery in it there's real mastery i
think in in watching other actors work
in watching how they do things and i i
made a few films with dustin hoffman and
i used to do the same thing
with him too yeah um because it is it is
like a master class you know if you if
you're interested in continuing to flex
the muscle as an actor and you're not
like going to
like i don't never had like an acting
coach because i went to drama school for
four years and i was like that is quite
enough of that
i'm just gonna go i'm ready
watch i'm ready and i'm gonna go i'm
going to go and watch
other people
yes oh it's my favorite i'd love i i
love hearing that because i i do it
myself um and and certainly being in a
scene with somebody
that present i imagine you had dustin
hoffman i can't imagine
a a more committed
you know uh scene partner to be with it
must just i think it was different it
was different every time wow as well
like
he just played i think that's what lots
of that lots of the great actors do is
they just play i mean i don't know i
it's fun i i love it i just love doing i
mean let me ask you specifically was he
just so was he loose i he seems so loose
in his work but i've also heard that
there was a lot of work before i mean to
be able to be that loose there's a lot
of preparation i think that's exactly
right it's like you know when you hear
an album that's been
recorded in one session like wilco
record they record their music
they record on the day they record but
the preparation that goes into that day
when sit in a room together is huge and
i i think dustin's like that
because there were so many things at his
fingertips that he wanted to try and it
wasn't
it wasn't forced and in a way all of
them worked it was fair it was really
fascinating i know exactly um yeah i
want to go back to that bench scene
though what
if
if to the best of your memory um because
i want to know everything about goodwill
hunting it's one of those movies that
the few i'm there are a handful of them
when they when they're on they they come
on i have to watch them i
um
i discover something new about that
movie to love every time i see it and
it's i can't tell you how many times but
and obviously you were such a beautiful
component of it um
so i just want to know oh yeah just
beautiful well he i'll tell you that
that um
that day
so we were shooting in it's so lame that
i can't remember that that beautiful
problem
that's right in the center of boston
what is it um
boston public garden but boston public
art you know what's more embarrassing
than you forgetting which is like it's
that you shot there at one day or you
didn't even shoot there you went there
to visit i lived
on boston public garden
uh for about a month and a half
yeah that's embarrassing yeah you didn't
know that and minnie i would
thank you i was i i love honesty i was
there um in fact uh i don't mean to
laugh into this although he would have
laughed um when robin passed away uh and
there were
people ev it was one of the i took so
many photos of it was such a michael i
wish he had i'm sure he saw but it was
such a beautiful display of um of love
of for him
people wrote in shock
different quotes from his movies and and
thank you letters oh i'm getting chills
thinking about it but it was um oh my
god where are they yeah all over it and
it was so spread out that it was almost
it wasn't the whole park but it was most
of the sidewalks in the park
that i think i saw pictures yeah
i think i saw some and it was
i mean listen that that
he and that film
and matt and ben and stellen skarsgard
and gus van sant like they
they're they're etched into my heart
like they they just are and on funnily
enough on that particular day when i go
on just to hang out to watch matt work
to watch robin work and to watch them
work together
um at lunchtime you know we were
everyone was sitting around like we were
in the park and we were just
you know got your food from catering
everyone was just like chilling in the
park and robin was telling some he was
just having some jokes to the crew he
just started telling he was just telling
some jokes
and obviously
they were laughing a lot and then there
were you know there were people from
office buildings who'd also come to eat
their sandwiches oh yeah it's a very
popular kind of
so what was like people started
wandering over
and
suddenly there were like 25 people
some 30 people
and then
you could see people coming i mean you
could see people coming out along and
running down into the park like people
would run to tell people come
come see this it was totally free
cell phones yeah and suddenly he had
this crowd
and they put him on an apple box and he
just
he just he just did his thing for like
45 minutes he just played a set in in
the park in the middle of like this this
super like hardcore
hardcore scene
and like i
what i remember about him was the energy
the energy that is required to do that
because like you said he's working he's
doing that thing which is now like
iconic we know and and it requires a lot
of focus energy whatever but he um it's
his lunch time i'm just thinking
practically like
he didn't stop like that's that's the
thing it was
he was always he was always on
he was always
working through
whether it was material or emotions or
thoughts and
he was just lovely and expressing it i i
remember he i got to work with him
briefly and it was the same thing many
it was um in between takes he was and
doing characters for that's what struck
me about this
sidewalks of um that park when he passed
away it was
because i read all of them and it was
the amount of
quotes these characters he was
responsible for that people love that
are like etched into like you said
etched into people's hearts um but he it
was that there are very few people that
make movie after movie that you go
you know that it's it's it's rare
i went to the memorial his memorial in
san francisco that was so beautiful and
as i was as i was walking down the
street i heard this like clip clock clip
clock behind me and someone went minnie
and i turned around and it was eddie
izzard who you know i didn't i'd done
this show for fx with years before and
and we
went down we were sitting and i said how
come you know robin and eddie said when
i was a young comedian
robin did this buy-out he did a buy-out
of a club which i guess i didn't know
that that was like something that that
other comics do for each other like when
someone they really believe in someone's
talent and they do a buy out of a room
and they fill it so every ticket is sold
so people could see eddie
and they're you know
we sat with our very different
experiences of robin at this beautiful
memorial and
his daughter gave the most beautiful
speech and billy crystal
gave a speech that started out it was
the funniest thing you ever heard
and then it went all the way
to the end of the rainbow with i think
the whole theater was in tears like it
was good it was amazing yeah it was
amazing i would love to have been there
and i i got to talk to his daughter
she's just
she's like feels like she carries the
torch she's such a smart um funny i
agree with zelda if you're listening oh
you're listening to this it's amazing
the fire is the fire burns strongly in
that one yes yeah so so lucky you got to
be that witness that oh just to
witness that was that scene
do you do you remember being surprised
because i remember thinking when i saw
that i think it was the first time that
i i had seen him
really um restrained like that and
internal and um
i don't know if you had seen him perform
that way before but it was was it
surprising
that film
you know it was like a cabal and gus van
sant was this quiet extraordinary
i don't know what the head of a cabal is
called but he was
that's a good one that should be that if
it's i like king kabob
so he suggested was king cabal and in
the most in
the the quietest most self-deprecating
most extraordinarily observant way and
the notes that he would give and the
encouragement and the direction
was
the best in any film i've ever been in
shows
watching him
direct the boys and then direct
everybody and he said right by the
camera oh he was never back at a monitor
he was base was like at the
in
you know in the certainly in the close
work very so very intimate who's with
you guys
and
i'm thinking specifically of the scene
where he leaves that such a god what a
raw
beautiful scene one of those scenes
where i think
to get through that it just felt so real
i'm so curious about the environment
that was created to get there to get to
those
raw emotions
that is a really good point when i'm
telling you
between
gus and the producer chris moore and
matt and ben and just the entire tone
of the set it was tuned to this thing we
were making
and everybody was in on it and everyone
was part of it they believed in it there
was they were invested a hundred percent
and like that scene was as written as
ben both wrote it it had never changed
and it was the scene that i uh that i
auditioned with and then when we
auditioned and it was
it was mental how good it was because we
loved it so much we already knew where
it was and i and gus doesn't he doesn't
get in the he doesn't get in the way of
when he sees something happy he'll get
in the way when something isn't working
but if something is
i think he loves actors and he wants
them to he wants them to do their thing
and then see how he needs to kind of
help what's happening exactly so and
when you trust a director so much like
gus van sant and he's not coming in and
working things out with you it must be
so encouraging to just kind of lean
into what you're already doing it must
be uh
definitely and he would give you know
four word sentences like of notes like
it would be so incredibly specific and
also jean-yves who is the amazing
cinematographer who who is also now so
sadly past he was a a documentary
cameraman and
his stillness and his faithfulness to
the story being told and this and also
like this reverence like that i remember
that from the set which is rare for
you know these two young these two young
guys what they'd created and how they
were how they were manifesting it there
was so much joy in it and it was a huge
amount of work for them it was so i just
remember there being so much joy on that
set and it just it being
amazing i that's interesting uh many
they say she was a coming from
documentaries i'm now there is that kind
of handheld um like he's capturing
something that we're not even meant to
be watching it has that such organic
is that scene in particular i'm now
thinking of um were you you're urging
him to stay you're urging him to
communicate and
uh you know he's so locked up it's it's
it's heartbreaking it's it's really god
i'm getting chills thinking about it i
think it was it was really it was a
really interesting piece of writing in
that they
they
they got rid of the girl at the top of
the third act
and i
and what is so bold about that is that
notion that if you have written it right
and i suppose if you cast it right and
you have someone who will you need her
to haunt that last yes yes
that last act so that when he is you
know i'm going to see about a girl you
know what it is he's going to yeah you
love her too exactly
that line i mean it's almost like they
knew they were protecting that line they
knew how great that i'm going to see
about a girl uh moment was that they
which is why your casting was so
important and and uh so perfect because
you are so
likable yeah like you said you're really
rooting for for that um to happen
uh and and so sometimes you have to miss
characters
you have to miss people and
things often are overwritten and people
want to get their money's worth and
they're like no we gotta have one screen
but
getting rid of a character that you love
is such a powerful tool it's a risk yeah
but it's it it worked it worked so
beautiful i mean so many things work so
beautifully which is why that film i
think is you know
one of one of the greats
[Music]
would you say that you're a curious
person i would say that i would agree
and i'd like learning new things as
listeners of the show know i've been
attempting to learn spanish what's
something new that you learned recently
i recently learned how to pickle
cucumbers and make pickles oh yeah yeah
and i learned that on an amazing website
called one dream yeah one dream they
have courses that are given by experts
obviously because you don't want you
don't want to take a course given by an
amateur so they get but they get the
best of the best i'm taking a grilling
course
um taught by these chefs that are from
the culinary institute of america one
dream has thousands of hours of content
from brands like the great courses which
includes programs created in partnership
with national geographic smithsonian
history the culinary institute of
america like you said
and many more and amazing collections
from kino lorber magellan tv and craftsy
it's very cool it's a great time to
learn something new and it's the perfect
way to do it sign up now through our
special url to get this great offer a
14-day free trial of unlimited access
why not do it go now to onedream.com
long that's w-o-n-d-r-i-u-m
dot com slash long
l-o-n-g
one dream dot com
slash
long hello again
[Music]
i'm so interested to see
the duel
which is the movie matt and ben and
nicole holocene have written and ridley
scott is directing and they've just they
shot it in they shot it uh
last year sort of at the book ends of of
lockdown and it's the first thing
they've written together since goodwill
hunting
yeah i wonder if it's just because wow
you if you
do something like create something like
that so
you know lasting so like you said
because it's a classic um maybe it is
the fear of uh
i don't know how do we do that again how
do we how do we oh my god i'm sure yeah
i'm sure and i think also they were
actors yeah like matt and ben
they wanted it was like a vehicle for
them to act i i really feel like you
know again you sort of talk about
polymaths
um
they wrote that so they could they could
be these characters that they knew so
well yeah and i think it was
i think
maybe they were as surprised as
everybody oh yeah yeah
well they seemed like it was writing
well many when you talk you talk about
establishing that character who then
disappears i'm i'm now which they did
obviously but i'm thinking
uh about that montage it's so hard to do
having done like a few of those romantic
comedy type things like that the getting
to know you stuff is so and having
written well i mean that's the toughest
stuff to write too so it felt like
um that
when you guys
you know he helps you with your work and
and you go off and have fun um together
and you're horsing around in the little
tchotchke shop i always wondered uh how
much of that was it was that all
improvised were you guys just running
around
uh
[ __ ] around
it's so cool because they you know i and
i think this is true that when they
publish the script
matt and ben published the script that
they'd written
but if you if you sit with that script
and you watch the movie you'll be able
to see how much
improvisation was there we improvised
the burger scene was improvised
the bring the bring me another my tie
was improvised
but the the you know the set the the
amazing set pieces like the that that
beautiful turning
scene in um
in the coffee shop when they're when
he's
they're talking about math and
and she's asking him how he knows so
much and also at the race course
like that was the very
they were either running the camera and
i did i can't remember it was either the
first take or they were just running the
camera because i'd that i bet we'd all
bet everybody oh
yeah and there was one called um
it was like sweet misty or something and
misty is my stepmother and i was like oh
i'm gonna put like 20 bucks on that
and and i won and the dog run the dog
ran and the dog won and they caught that
and that is me that is absolutely
me winning like 150 dollars oh i love
that you know what's brilliant about
minnie what's amazing about your
performance is that you um that moment i
know it's so well it does of course seem
organic it's oh my god
the exuberance is so real but like it
doesn't it doesn't seem out of place it
doesn't seem like oh that's clearly
that happened because so the rest of the
performance is equally
you know organic it matches the organic
nature that's that's like
that's the litmus test for i think a
great performance like you can't tell
but you know that when when writers
let you do that or direct that you do
they
they
and when writers aren't um god if they
were ever a script to be precious about
because every word was amazing it would
have been that one but they weren't they
they wanted really they wanted everyone
just to bring what what they could to it
i mean yeah no we you know we
90 99 of what we shot was what they
wrote but there were there were moments
particularly with
he'd fallen asleep when we
he'd fallen asleep on set because he was
so exhausted matt um
and that beautiful scene when
she's in bed with him asking him that
she wants to meet his friends yeah yeah
and they they built the scaffolding
geneva scuff here the the
cinematographer said let's just build a
platform up above and we'll just shoot
down on them and so they they built this
thing with him like passed out because
he was so tired from
[Music]
working on the script and acting in
every scene
and then gus was like just go
just go and get into bed with him and
just start just start talking and all
you have to do is end up
with saying
you know
i want to meet i want to meet oh chucky
or i'm going to call him up or whatever
so that whole thing was matt was asleep
and i you know i just like woke him up
doing the stuff oh my god that's so cool
oh [ __ ] minnie i could
talk about this forever wow i haven't
talked about this really i haven't
talked about this ever actually and i
haven't i haven't thought about it in so
long and it's such i'm just realizing
what a sweet memory oh good it is well
um that's good to hear because i love it
is for me i mean as an audience member
and i'm sure for so many people
listening it's like a it's sacred it's a
it's um it's a big part of our
culture now you know that movie for i
don't think i'm exaggerating um
i i yeah i i often wonder about
movies like that and and i friends we
we've known each other for uh many years
you know uh yeah we see each other
occasionally and our friend alexander
valente who i hope is listening
oh my god
alexandra you better be listening better
be like hey i'm gonna alex how about
this if you're if you're listening right
now um text mini
just text mini the emoji of the flag of
bulgaria
okay just sender of the bulgarian flag
and many okay by the way this is this is
how long we've all known each other
seriously because just quickly going
back to google hunting yeah
i reference a professor valenti oh the
movie oh my god no [ __ ]
no [ __ ]
oh that and it's a sweet alexandra um
yeah i really miss her all my austin
from me too so but you'll be back you'll
be back soon yeah yeah yeah i love
austin i mean i love austin texas but
it's
it's tricky when you like when you're
working and when you're off you want to
sort of be home
you know and also i don't know this past
couple of years good guard with the
traveling i mean it's a really kind of a
non-starter i want to get to talk about
your podcast called mini questions i
love the name isn't that hard to name a
podcast
did you find that really yeah really
really
really hard to name it but this is a
good one yeah you landed on a good one
i'm curious what else was in contention
all the answers was the one that i
wanted and there's already there was
already a podcast called all the answers
oh really that's how many podcasts
are that's so funny that's how many
podcasts there are yeah and then it was
tell me everything and then it was
many questions well which
sorry yeah i didn't come up with morgan
my one of my producers came up with it
um so are the are the questions actually
mini or was the pun just too hard to was
it too hard to avoid it's seven
questions and so i was thinking also
because it comes from well the
inspiration was from um
i wrote this
no
it came from priest
marcel
the great french literary titan
who he created in the 19th century he
created this it was like a parlor game
it was a whole list of questions
and and people would it was like a
person sort of like a personality test
or a personality analysis i always loved
it
so i did this i did like a redux version
with my own questions so it was it's a
mini version and then
many questions and i am questioning so
it's a really perfect you know it's a
it's a pun and it's also
you know accurate well many i mean
life is short with justin long we we had
to
we couldn't avoid it
and like especially when your name is a
length you know mini
if your name is the length you have to
incorporate it
we'll drive that but also like we tried
like in the driver's seat yeah
there was some there was some pretty
sort of lame attempts on my part the
driver ring force
uh yeah the driver yeah dr uh driver
baby driver driving driving miss minnie
ah yeah oh okay
that was
terrible yeah
well they can't all be winners they can
all be many questions
they come with any questions
but it's been really amazing doing it i
gotta say i love it i bet well you're so
inquisitive you're so bright and fat i i
would i would like to hear you talk i
i'm enjoying hearing you now so
uh
and i and i love the idea of uniform
questions you know i'd love to hear how
it's so revealing just how people
approach um the same questions
it's true and also like the discipline
of um
i shouldn't give you any i shouldn't
give you any tips don't know if you're
going to come on my podcast i want to go
in pretty blind it is revealing and it
is what you think is
deep is sometimes shallow and what you
think is going to be shallow is is a lot
of times deep but it's a i wanted to
create like an anthology i wanted to
create like a cultural anthology of
interesting people
asking you know asking them the same
question so that you can really cross
reference it and go oh what did tony
blair say about
um
what his last meal would be what did
justin long
say was
the trait he least liked about himself
you know
those
i don't know if that's one of them
that's
it it is it's been one of the there's
this you know the the actor author
kind of rack on to
stephen fry yes of course i love
raconteur he's
he's he's one of the most amazing people
ever and when he answered that question
like it went into you know it started
out with it started out with the food
but i mean talk about protein it went
from that
all the way out into the outer reaches
of the universe and beyond all the way
through the sort of creationism all the
way back around through the bible and
back to you know what the egg and ships
or whatever it was he said he liked and
i i just i just sat there like this yeah
through the whole thing by the way
thanks a lot he said anything way to
raise the bar stupid try i'm mine is
just gonna be surface oh i like uh soup
dumplings mine will be very certain no
chelsea oh chelsea handler the other day
she was like spaghetti and clams yeah
next like that was what yeah
that's what she said i was like anything
else yeah spaghetti clams well i just
want someone to make that for me well
it's funny my brother we've had this
conversation my brother we did the
podcast together and christian said he
had a good point where he said um i
don't know that i would want uh one of
my favorite like to have that
pleasurable experience before i i die
you know i like a reminder of some of
the great parts of life and i which i
think food is and certainly your
favorite oh my god
chris christian christian is your
brother yeah yeah christian what do you
have to lose
in that in that in those last moments
like don't you want to be eating ice
cream well i think that i think he it's
the it's the adding to the fear adding
to the um
fear of leaving this because you know
there's so many that's one of the
reasons i i fear death is um
because of all the great the the
pleasures i'm looking out the window now
it's just like just seeing the nate
being in nature and and certainly food
is one of those so i think his point was
like the reminder of
yeah of what you're going to leave
behind yeah the offerings but i gotta i
gotta tell you when
if you know
that it's happening and you know that
it's coming and it is literally a
one-way street that you cannot avoid and
you are with that person who is
leaving there is something it's kind of
like to the power of a thousand that
each
little cucumber sandwich or the last
vodka and tonic or the last whispered i
love you becomes
magnified and amplified by the fact that
it is
it is at the end of this beautiful life
and
there's also something
there's also and i don't know if it's
one's brain making it up because you
know i lost my mom recently and i'm i've
been
you know wondering about
for you know where she is
and
but when i was with her when she was
dying
i couldn't help but feel that she was
beginning this other adventure i had
this feeling i had i had this feeling
that it was
this thing was ending but as with every
single thing that ends it could only
herald the beginning of something else
and i don't know what that is and i i
don't exactly but i i definitely had
that sense i that's been coming up a lot
uh in my life on the show many and i'm
so sorry you went through that i'm sorry
that you lost her
um
that's yeah she was lovely yeah i bet i
bet well she
yeah she left behind a really lovely
person i bet she was very proud of you
yes she was yeah she definitely was yeah
good um yeah but the idea of beginning
again um i just started meditating uh 10
i got the 10 percent happier
it's i can't recommend it enough but um
they that comes up a lot uh the idea of
you know if thoughts enter your mind um
it's about separating yourself from the
ego and i guess death is the ultimate
experience of that of
god that's that's a that's exactly
that's exactly right yeah yes but to
witness it it must have been also very
comforting it sounds like
she had there was a degree of acceptance
which is beautiful
it was
yeah there was
it was so fast it that was what was
shocking wow but she had
you know she she was 84 and she lived
this extraordinary life it's very hard
it's very hard i keep thinking that i'm
gonna i keep getting this feeling like
oh my god i gotta call mom yeah like i
keep thinking it can't possibly be
forever like the hat i have to
i have to see her again like that your
brain can't really comprehend right
that they're not there forever yeah and
i do think that's it's part of grief and
it's part but it's fascinating
in a weird way when i can sort of be the
observer with it to look and see what
this journey of grief is and that
ultimately grief is just another
profound expression of love oh that's
really well said my friend is struggling
with and my mother just like we lost our
grandmother recently and so my mom
i'm sorry oh yeah but we and we were all
really close so it's my first real bout
with grief and and it's been
interesting my friend is going through
something now and she had a really
she's she's got a really healthy
beautiful perspective on it which is to
um be more present so she's present to
the pain and
and and with the idea that it's going to
pass and um
and and and it won't
lead to suffering you know the pain will
be there you confront it and she's just
got such a beautiful outlook on it and
uh oh my goodness i'm writing a thing at
the moment and i was writing about mum's
death
and one of the observations that i made
when i
you know was in the hospital was
that death is so much more akin to birth
than anybody ever talks about and that
notion of contraction and release
and
that
literal pulse and figurative pulse
and
riding
riding a wave but i
you have to let go it's like the very
first thing that you do when you give
birth to a child the very first act as a
mother is your body literally lets go
of this person
and
actually a lot of parenting
is letting go of your child and letting
them oh my god
and it's the same when somebody dies it
really is it's like there's pain you
need support while you're going through
it it is a journey
you need someone to hold your hand and
to lean on
you need to know that you're safe and
that you're loved it's the same it's the
same setting it was the same
setup when my mom exited than it was
when i gave birth to my son and that was
a very similar feeling for me which is
almost
i don't know if it's like
almost like she was being born into
death or something i'm i'm i'm only i'm
looking down because i'm writing this
down because it's
it's blowing my mind how this keeps
coming up in the same uh in terms of
grief and and moving through pain it
it's profound how how it changes you and
i had a weird mystical i think i know
magical experience with um
it's too much to get into but it was
something in nature it was uh having to
do with the turtle i was asking my
grandmother for a sign and
the profound the very real so it was so
clear that um it was her wanting me to
not forget or um you know because i used
to equate those two the the
the idea of remembering somebody with
letting go um
and and i don't i don't think those two
are
tied together anymore so i i got the
sense that i was she was asking me to
let her go and it was
i i i was you i don't know if you've had
similar experiences where you've seen
her or felt her out in the world
whenever i think about her a bird flies
over my head there's some avian
connection which is
strange and i don't know if i'm seeing
signs because i so desperately want to
see
her and signs and know that she's okay
but
i've heard that it's maybe too soon to
be dreaming about her and to feel her
out in the world but i i do i feel her
in every living thing i feel her in the
sunshine and
i was just walking through the park
yesterday here in london
and i've been running through that park
through this whole winter and this lock
down in january and february and it was
so gnarly and i would run every single
day
and
seeing the trees stripped and looking
like they were dead like really
genuinely just those
silhouettes yeah and walking through the
park yesterday with this
verdant green and these huge leaves and
everything that had come back and
everything that had regenerated and been
and been reborn and i
i felt her so profoundly um
she loved nature and i can only believe
that she's
energetically just completely still part
of that yeah and part of you observing
that you as an observer of nature as a
participant in the natural world i i
think i wonder if she's amplified
that feeling of participation for you
i'm sure
that's so interesting i wonder if that's
what it is because we shared that well
she gave that to me yes yes very early
on um you know she could name every
plant and every tree and she could tell
you when it when it would need to be
pruned or what it was good for
medicinally yeah like she was she really
yeah
she was she was amazing about she was
amazing about nature
she was a great painter and wow yeah she
was
well it she must have yeah must have
really valued it to to have uh
encouraged you to go to that school uh
that beardsley um
yeah
she
exactly and because she'd been there
she'd been there during the war you know
oh my god
yeah and in fact henry if henry or
that's my dog walking um
if he's kind of an [ __ ] oh really
what type of dog
um
well
he is i did one of those 23andmes with
him you know whatever it is like the dog
version of that and he's he's a a
maltese a shih tzu and a pekingese
and he's also an [ __ ] oh oh i didn't
know that was an actual breed
um what [ __ ] yeah yeah well shih tzu
sounds like it i mean
quite quite appropriate but he he was he
was
he was a funny little rescue and he's he
just doesn't like anyone really except
me and my boyfriend well it's a good
thing he likes both of you oh that's
good it's it would suck
what's his name
bob
bob
yeah that's such a good name for a dog
oh my god that's great he's got a crazy
underbite oh yeah he crazy crazy like
crazy under bite and
full blood no he'll growl at night he'll
growl it he'll growl at my boyfriend you
know if he gets too close to me on the
sofa but it's hilarious
he does he just like he then like my
boyfriend then leans over him and he's
like
you're not the boss
that's right that's funny
he has the alpha bob
he does have to alpha blog bob's tiny
um well
i'm yeah minnie i'm sorry but i i it
does sound like um
you you're growing into it i mean that's
that's
not resisting i guess that's a big part
of grief i'm learning is that uh you
can't resist it you can't fight it you
gotta kind of like no i mean i think
there are days where you do yeah
you just rail against it yes that is now
part of your journey that ex huge
expression of grief and of sadness
and it then moves into you know a lot of
them just be i'll think about something
amazing that she said to me or taught me
or something incredibly embarrassing
that she did
she did that all the time yeah and and
suddenly you are you are literally
cobbling together
your
relationship with your parent after they
die and and your relationship to their
death and your relationship to your
being able to move on in your life
so
we do so much in this world like if you
think about it like we are just so not
encouraged to feel our pain we're
encouraged to just dose it and suppress
it don't feel pain pain is bad grief
should grief should be taught in school
i know death should be taught in schools
and i don't understand it
like what my kid has had to
to watch like as he's watched this
watched his grandmother die and watched
this whole process
and i was so sad the other day and he
just came and he put his hand on my back
and he was just like
he just stood with me he just stood with
me in it until i'd stopped crying until
it had passed
and then i turned him and like we had
this conversation i was like i want you
to know
that don't be afraid i know it's it's it
must be awful seeing your mama cry like
this it must be awful for you
but you don't have to fix it
you know everything that you just did
which was just to stand and be with me
in there
let me tell you that's the that's the
that's all you need to do and you know
listening to him talk about it and talk
about this process like they kids should
be talking about this in school because
it it comes and it hits you
and when you're little if this happened
to you when you're little i just
i can't bear it come i i i i wish it
would be
[Music]
this segment and you know i love a good
segment and this one is brought to you
by bud light seltzer iced tea and bud
light seltzer lemonade the perfect
combination for summer so this segment
the theme is
spill the tea do you have something you
would like to spill that you'd like to
announce maybe yeah i'd like to spill
that i've been uh working in bulgaria
i've been enjoying it so much i can't
wait to come back the one thing about
bulgaria that's
kind of lacking is that they don't seem
to have bud light seltzer here so i've
been missing it a lot and i'm jealous
that you've been getting to enjoy it
what flavors have you been enjoying up
there at the lake massachusetts oh you
know i love cherry limeade you spilled
that tea already this summer ice is
delicious you know about bud light
seltzer the delicious hard seltzer from
bud light with no bud light in it now
bud light seltzer is here with the
perfect flavors for summer with the bud
light seltzer lemonade variety pack and
the brand new bud light seltzer iced tea
variety pack a 5 alcohol 100 calories
and they're gluten free so if you'd like
to try all of these flavors and every
permutation of all these flavors you can
now do that with the bud light seltzer
ice tea and lemonade mix pack you can
combine to your heart's content remember
you can get all the different flavors of
bud light seltzer delivered at bud
light.com
delivery or
you go to a local neighborhood grocery
convenience store liquor store and
have a human interaction and get it
yourself
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
hello hello again
we'll meet again
[Music]
i have a bit of a um
mini questions myself uh not that we
took it from you but uh and they're
probably
a little more um superficial but uh
but i like super fast okay good um and i
and i quickly i do also want to mention
and we will in the intro outro but i
want to talk about modern love uh it's
on amazon your amazon series and um
cinderella a new cinderella sony movie
coming out on amazon prime in september
um yes
modern love has been out
is that like a video
yeah this is season two yeah and it's
yeah it's an anthology series they're
they're half hour episodes and it was
started um
at the new york times then they're true
stories they're all like they're true
stories of people
um
and it then it became a podcast and then
it became a tv show and it's it's really
it's really beautiful
it's really um i i loved
i loved it i i love acting
i just love it you're very good at it
you uh i i like that you keep doing it
because you are um
god you know what what um i'm now
thinking of conviction
um oh my god with sami yeah yeah uh
what are you how great are you in that
and so and that but you got that boston
accent must have been
doing that boston accent was with were
there memories of
good will hunting did you lean at all on
on those guys
i really had to
no i mean i really had to learn that
from the ground up yeah like that's a
tough but yeah
it was uh yeah it's actually rhode
island
which is yeah uh it's but it's it's
similar
but it's it's not exactly the same but
i mean i pretty i just had henry i henry
was
two and a half months old
three months old when i shot that movie
and i it was so funny because i was like
i just because i'd been so huge when i
was pregnant
and when i you know got to do that movie
you know i was definitely somewhat
smaller but i was still but literally
bursting at the seams and it's so funny
when i watch the movie i just see this
like super milky exhausted new mother oh
really that's funny milky um but i've
never heard that used as an adjective i
was really milky
um really milky yeah i'm always so
impressed by good boston accent because
like i had to do it once and like you
said [ __ ] is it hard it's like everyone
can do that
and why everyone can do this sort of
like where's pack the car and all that
but but the way you guys approached it
was um
when sammy was great i remember and
shout out he was so excited so good uh
shout out to our friend john togo um
friends with alex and samurai togo who's
from rockland how are you shout out to
rockland um he helped sami
he recorded a lot did he yeah he
recorded a lot of those lines for for
sam and um i think he should sam had a
great great he had a great accident in
that movie he was so good in that film
he really he i mean so was hilary swank
i mean she's like she's a big beast yeah
beast amazing amazing
yeah it was awesome i am i loved it tony
tony goldwyn directed a lot of that
movie with henry tucked inside his
jacket because we we shot in detroit and
ann arbor
i was just going to say like it doesn't
for tony goldwyn um for the you know
actor on scandal but he's also just a
one like such a sensitive wonderful
director he he's such a um i've been
around him when when people meet him and
i i he's one of those people that you
can witness other people
be within seconds be charmed by you know
they're
absolutely he has that effect on people
he's such a charming like lovely and so
so that story is perfect that he
he had henry in his
yeah he had henry in his inside his
jacket for a lot of it and i was you
know i was breastfeeding every like
every couple hours or every hour and a
half and they were while henry was in
the jacket lovely
yeah
i would take him out of tony's gym okay
okay okay
um
um oh yeah well it's good good memories
being around all those people during
that time um
i also many just weirdly like
i don't know why this stuck in my head
you have such great work verdan panoply
i'm writing down like you have such a
rich vocabulary um
when you say vagrant vodka tonic
yeah we used to [ __ ] her and tonight
vodka and tonic it immediately stopped
i immediately think of um
that elton john's song uh to get you on
your feet again i take you a couple of
vodka and tonics immediately exactly
exactly it's just like it gets you on
your feet again yeah i love that song um
that is uh that has nothing to do with
anything um
that's just something that popped into
my head that's the great thing about
podcast you say
oh you shouldn't say whatever i'm sure
you're more disciplined um with your
thoughts what is your most commonly used
emoji would you say do you use emojis
yeah i do oh um look right now
the heart with an arrow through it oh
yeah and
and also the
the the kind of eye roll oh okay
give me a break yes i often go there um
usually about myself like it's something
i've just texted like oh sorry about
that me too yeah me too okay
yeah if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you play
uh tennis play oh yeah you have a
favorite player
i mean
i
love serena williams i mean i i
i love her it was
i you know i just was watching the
french open and i was very i'm i'm so
sorry i'm forgetting the name of the of
the really amazing girl who beat her but
i love her i love watching her win
um i hate watching her liz
but she's i just i love the kind of
athlete that she is that's why you're
you're expressing a microaggression
about the person who beat her
maybe
why i've forgotten her name but she's
she's incredible she beats smoothie
rooms like she's she had a she had a
very good day um
i like how i like how much she loves her
i love how much she loves herself and
values yeah herself yeah um yeah and
passionate she seems very passionate um
yeah if you could have one snack food
for the rest of your life what would it
be
blueberries oh wow
that's healthy too
i love them but they have to they can't
be mushy they have to be like snappy and
tight and delicious but that's a tall
order for for a whole thing of
blueberries do you have to go through
them and weed out the i do you do i do
yeah i do i do i i
i pop them into the sink from my
breakfast table oh that's very that's a
lot of work um
but if you love them sometimes i give
them to my dog
he likes them oh bob
[Laughter]
uh bob uh what what is what what was the
movie that you um
that you were so excited you were
excited to show your son when he was of
a certain age that that you uh you're
like i can't wait to
kind of share this with him
well it was tarzan oh yeah it was which
i actually was the old school tony
goldwyn was was tony goldwyn was tarzan
it was the the disney the disney
animation
and um i was jane
and
it was the cutest thing when he watched
i showed up to him when he was like
three four
and he went and he was listening and he
knew it was me and he just kind of kind
of like looking at me and then looking
by the tv and then he went and looked
behind the tv oh that's so funny just
trying to he couldn't couldn't make
headphones but like that was a big
it was a big favorite he's like he's
like i don't want to be a dragon anymore
i want to be like a feral like hunk
who lives with apes i want to be that
yeah and by the way how come your voice
is there and you're sitting right next
to me here it must be that
yeah
that's really disrespectful how did how
did how do you explain that what's that
conversation like
no i didn't i was just like yeah it's
mommy's job yeah yeah so he thought that
the job was like a magic trick it's good
that's true you want to normalize it or
typicalize it
i think when i think when you're
referring to to phrases and things i
think you can
use
yeah yeah yeah of course maybe maybe no
that's not just respectable to phrases i
guess it depends on what the phrase is
um it depends what the phrase identifies
yes yes well what is your go-to karaoke
song
you're out with valenti at at the the
alamo
yeah at the high ball oh my god or at
the the gower gulch
remember that place i do my god it's
gone i was just there it's gone memories
of like it's gone wait
in fact that's what i that's so funny
and also
joel edgerton and his brother oh that's
right
there are a bunch there are so many
memories at the gal gulch in los angeles
which is sadly no more yeah but karaoke
wise
um
i'm a big it's really it's jambalaya
jambalaya i don't
wow
i forgot you wanted to love that song
you i now this is like we don't have
time for this but you i didn't know that
you want you were a recording artist
before you were like i didn't know i was
what that's yeah that was my other life
what and what was my other life what
type of music it just
it was like it's real it was really
amazing it's really americana like this
i've got a couple albums on
i got a couple albums that are on
spotify and it's super it was all like
you know i listened to neil young and
bob dylan and joni mitchell growing up
so it's kind of
and a lot of wilco
a lot of that that kind of vibe oh cool
my favorite um who was your very first
celebrity crush
yeah dan dey lewis oh yeah that's right
disgust uh
d-day it really was also
uh paul michael klaser oh okay yeah
and i think they're very similar well
mine was mark paul gasler
um
i don't know it just sounded like it uh
if you had to get a tattoo
yeah you have do you have or another
exception yes yeah another one
what would the next one be oh my god
oh my god it would it would it would be
my son's name oh yeah you know it would
be or it would be something
um
it would be something that was more
meaningful than like you know the rose
that i have that everyone said would
fade and it has not faded it is as
bright and vivid as the day that i got
it when i was 15.
and lyden said i was 18. it's faded
that's funny
it's funny i was gonna get like a
leaping tiger i was gonna get this
leaping tiger with like scratch marks
and blood droplets and the tattoo guy
was like yeah no you're not gonna want
that
you really don't want that pick
something else oh thank god oh my god
thank god oh he tucked you up really
that's fine he saved me he saved me from
a really terrible tattoo well you know
next time i see you we don't have time
for it now but i i you got to remind me
or have alex tell you the story about
sami's tattoo
about rockwell's
[ __ ] the rooster
um and also we couldn't we can't use it
because i don't want to uh you know him
to hear that uh so favorite fruit we got
was blueberries um
who who would you want to play you in
your biopic
oh my god it's like you'd have to play
yourself
i mean i'd have to play myself yeah yeah
i actually really would
like to
or maybe
yeah i mean or dandelion kind of
or dan day lewis or paul michael glaze
yeah
the only people equipped um and who's
your favorite do you have a favorite uh
muppet did you watch the muppets growing
up
oh yeah animal animal yeah
and because that's what i was called at
school oh really
yeah because i had this crazy hair and
so i like
i was just i i had this crazy hair and i
was either called slash or animal
or 50p face like a 50p is like this
it's this hexagonal shaped coin in
england and because i've got such a kind
of
you know my jaw and my chin and the
whole thing so that i was called 50
people
and also but i love anna yeah he's a
great drama he comes up a lot great
drama he's a great drummer and he just
is so expressive i mean it's just it's
all id
sam the eagle would be my second one
funny my god minnie that's so he rarely
comes up but i think about him often
because oh he i he used to scare me he
was so authoritative and you had that
voice wasn't he but didn't when you
watched that when you watched the whole
investigation didn't robert muller like
remind you of him you totally told
robert mueller and um [ __ ] who ran for
president i i'm i can't belie uh not he
looked like sam waterston a little bit
uh he here john kerry
yes yes john gary looks like sam the
eagles yes but sammy feels just so he
just he's just
i love him he has to make me feel very
safe i'm sorry that he made you feel
scared that's interesting well only
because of his um yeah i mean i guess i
was well because i was in college when i
was watching and i was afraid of
authority um
what about dogs or cats do you prefer
uh dogs
of course bob you have a very aggressive
one um beetles are the rolling stones
beetles and do you have a favorite stuff
like if you were to do a beatles song
but i wouldn't dance to that oh no i and
i yeah it's that's it's so tricky i will
dance the rolling stones but like i will
i'll play the beatles and like i'll play
myself oh cool
the songwriting is just bananas do you
have one that you um would haven't heard
in a while would like to like right now
if you were
you're at a jukebox at a bar
you pick any beatles fine
um uh across the universe that's my
favorite song yeah oh [ __ ] i it is and
i'm a
yeah and i'm a fan believer that that is
one of the greatest songs ever
and now for what you're sitting in um
thinking about you know your mother and
and being out there there's something
kind of
transcendent about that
song definitely and john john lennon
said the best thing about about
but it makes me think of because he's
gone and i think about it when he was
asked how he wrote songs he said i just
reach up i just reach up into the sky
and i pull them down before somebody
else does oh wow
great which i always i love that so much
yes i don't oh there's bob bob is saying
where we gotta go person the person that
i've got to see is here that's why he's
part of he decides to kill them minnie
you're so kind i i i it's so kind of you
to sit with me even when uh
thank you so much for sharing everything
and i'll be seeing you soon on on your
podcast yes i'll see you soon okay
bye love
[Music]
[Laughter]
so that just happened
yes very
verdant she uses words that are um you
know it's like classic her voice is
amazing obviously
amazing you know i know people use that
but it amazing
or really overuse that word
amazing and incredible but her voice is
amazing it is there's also quality about
it that's
it almost
sounds like a
whisper
yes but it still projects yes you know
it's like i can't do it but there's a
quality about it where everything is yes
that's understated but it comes out in
such a beautiful way still right it's
like like she's got um wonderful
masterful control of her breathing like
she's speaking beautifully in a library
you know yes well it's funny when i did
her show she referenced um
library how much she loves she's like oh
i'm such a i'm such a luddite
uh i love when people use like really
great words to describe their failings
you know that their shortcomings she was
like oh i am i'm so there's something so
i would say you're a bit of a luddite as
well
that's an understatement
yeah but i uh she was claiming that she
doesn't google or anything
i mean sort of joking she was
exaggerating but she said she loves
libraries it's funny that you mentioned
the library i can you write i can hear
that voice being used well to to it's a
wonderful effect such a good voice i
could i i could be happy listening to
her just like reading the phone book
um and she had you know it's not just
her voice she's also um
uh
so
patient and grounded and like
i just she's very measured yeah
something very measured about her yes
yes and she's like that i i really hung
up on that performance now but she was
like that at a at a young age it seemed
you know she did that movie
she's playing a college student and
there was something about that character
she seemed very mature but i think she
had to be yeah you know to bring that
out to to reveal how
bright and and
immature and like emotionally
immature like she brought so much
um gravitas like emotional
emotional crap he tossed that role that
that was interesting to think about uh
that movie
that um her character was pretty much
written out of the third act she was
talking about and
obviously the writing and the directing
is amazing in that movie but i think
um
she'd be selling herself short by not
saying that her performance
goes a long way in contributing to that
relationship
being something that
is like the payoff at the end yeah when
she's been gone for an entire act yeah
in order for that payoff to work you
need to really not only like her but
like them
and that i think that speaks volumes
about their chemistry and her
performance you don't both have to think
that her character's investment is
intrinsic to the final line in that
movie
i i know i well we talked about yeah i
know she uh and that's why afterwards
when she won the she won the the oscar
for that didn't she she was nominated
i don't think she won okay well but she
was nominated she's not the hardest to
get nominated for an oscar i
yes it's hard frankly i do how do you
know
but i um she i i i had heard this might
be and maybe we should cut this out but
it's like because it could be gossipy
but but i think it's known that she
and matt damon were dating when i
thought so yeah but then when
you know they went on this awards thing
and uh they were being talked about and
the movie was getting all this praise
i think he broke up with her
on now it's sounding gossip i know but i
think it was done kind of publicly oh
really like like she found out i i don't
know and it was so it's the reason why
she hadn't talked about it in a while oh
and interesting i think so and again
like i should check with many to make
sure this is okay to even talk about but
um there is i think there's a reason and
kind of like
uh uh i think they've since i think
she's able to talk about it so glowingly
and and with so much affection now
because i'm sure they did mend things
and she's said the nicest things about
matt damon and like you know it's years
ago 25 years years ago um god can you
believe this 25 years ago no oh man
crazy no it still feels like a very kind
of recent movie to me
um but anyway i think that's why she
hasn't talked about it um
well maybe we uh we got ourselves a
scoop maybe on life is short it could be
uh
it was cool to hear those stories though
about you know when you hear the behind
the scenes stuff about a movie that you
cherish so much it's like it's like
mind-blowing i don't like that oh she
talked about that scene where she
actually woke him up to tell him how
well do you know thinking back on that
it's
i can see that you know because it's not
not to take anything away from his
acting performance but it seemed like he
just just woke up it's really ann and
the horse winning the race and that
seemed like
he was genuinely excited exactly but
like i said to her it matches it doesn't
stand out as being any more natural or
more organic you know from the right but
it's like when you think about it yeah
it does make sense and and a strange
thing that occurred to me about that
waking up scene is um this is something
that very few people maybe
probably won't be able to relate to but
i always find it
for me personally i find it very
difficult sometimes like weirdly
challenging to wake up in a scene to
sleep on film on camera and what's
harder
sleeping or waking up
to do they're both quite difficult
realistically i i see what i try to do
is when i do a waking up thing i try to
sleep realistically i try to do both so
it's like i to me they go hand in hand
where it's like you i you just have to
be very s i mean the stillness of it and
then
you know i i do this with other things
behavior wise but like i i've tried to
note sometimes when i do wake up i've
done that before like you note when you
wake up how you wake up um and it's you
know what it is the waking up i think
that a lot of people don't do in their
performances so when you first wake up
there's a split second of a confusion
yes of where you are yes yes and it
takes a second for you to understand
what's happening yeah and i think too
often
if i may say so if i may criticize
actors in general yeah i think too often
people just wake up i think you're right
and they know exactly what's going on
who's talking to this talk yeah i think
you're right i think that'd be a really
good if you ever direct anyone waking up
i think it'd be uh you'd be good at that
but we have someone uh melanie wakes up
uh in uh ladies and gentlemen september
17th yeah but she's so good she doesn't
need no no direction on how to wake up
i'm saying like we didn't have to direct
that exactly yeah
we did though we directed the whole
movie but not her that's true she
directed her own performance yes
that was also a cool story about robin
williams that bench scene that that day
he shot that oh doesn't he like went on
an apple bot apple box yeah and did
material for all these uh
people around i've seen him do it
amazing yeah but like
of all days to do you know
this like iconic dramatic scene i know
again maybe a thing that
not many people can relate to but it's
like that
the amount of energy that is required
just to do a scene like that even though
it's still it's you have to be so
emotionally present and connected that
just i can't imagine doing that but he
had that he
well of energy i don't know where that
comes from
but
some people maybe he just was special
well speaking of special actors i didn't
know that daniel day-lewis story was
true i thought i always thought that was
legend yeah uh no i had heard i i had
talked to somebody else who claimed to
have been there you know what [ __ ] i i
wish do you think she was in the
audience for that performance she said
she was
she hesitated before she said so yeah i
think she saw um him play hamlet yeah i
don't know for sure if she was there for
that performance well i was just kidding
i'm not saying she's lying i'm saying
maybe she can inflate it exactly yeah i
know i
i
my regret now is not asking her about
that performance about how it because
i'm glad you didn't put her on the spot
yeah okay yeah because that might have
been tricky yeah yeah because you know
when you say something and it comes out
a certain way and then
if you were to reinforce that thing you
said it it'll it'll be like a lot it'll
sound like it right exactly because but
it's it's i now believe that that
happened which is yeah amazing
especially she knows him i mean like
i heard it yeah she calls him dan
i'm gonna start calling him dan day
lewis so people think i know him
danny day lewis
i wish
i was so curious about that performance
what happened yeah because i don't know
if he stopped in the middle of the show
he had a full breakdown didn't to the
point where he
stopped acting right yeah did he like go
become a carpenter a cobbler i think
italy yeah that's the story is that
story true i don't know but then i heard
he became a cobbler because of a role he
was playing oh uh but then i heard no
but i think it's you just became a
cobbler well well when he's on the
podcast
yeah yeah so it was like seeing your dad
the ghost of your dad on stage he must
have freaked you out oh my god so when
it comes to cobbling like what's
where do you start like when did you
start liking acting
do you do anything with your right foot
yeah stupid dude but yeah he would oh
can you imagine i do how scary would it
i wouldn't be able to i was just going
to say i wouldn't be able to talk to him
this is this is how scary he is that she
is kind of intimidating and grounded and
impressive and she's scared
i know you know and has known him since
she was like in childhood yeah and had
that really nice moment with him when he
was playing uh football but you know i
had heard a story on um
not sidewalks in new york uh there will
be blood
where you know there's another actor
playing the paul dano role i know and he
was so
not right not right yeah and and i think
part of it do you know who that actor
was we're not going to say his name no i
don't oh i don't he was so intimidated i
guess by holy [ __ ] daniel day lewis and
everyone was apparent on that it was
like because he was staying character he
was that guy that's crazy you imagine
that guy coming on set and like lighting
him and having to set marcus that means
paul dano has some big balls [ __ ] yeah
i'm hopefully a future guest yeah
it'd be great to get paul dano and his
big balls on this show
he's so good i thought you did a good
job defending my last meal position oh
and i stand by it yeah that the last
thing i would want before i knew it's
different if you don't know you're going
to die obviously then it's like you want
the most delicious thing you want to
enjoy life as much as possible but if
you knew you were like three minutes
away from dying
i don't think i'd want to go out with
such a wonderful experience i don't
think i'd be able to eat i'd be like i
get the other i get her
her argument i i just don't i just don't
think it's for me you know it makes it
it's a lovely way of looking at the
world yeah exactly but also then you
think if it's this is the next level of
of that question that if you are in that
position that probably means you did
something horrible to deserve that's
true so or not
i mean yeah or not thinking about the
movie that's true that's true and if you
did something but let's say you did say
that horrible
then
i don't think you'd be in the mental
state of wanting to soak into the beauty
of life you've just done something and
like you've just probably taken
someone's life well if you took
someone's life that means you probably
don't have much regard for life
including your own maybe so maybe you
would be like a sociopath who could be
like oh i do want to enjoy this fine you
know that's not like um like uh hannibal
lecter or jeffrey dahmer yes he well he
wasn't i think he was set to be probably
executed but if dahmer requested a human
for because you know he was a cannibal
would they give it to him as his last
meal you can't request humans you can't
right i thought but i thought the rule
was you get anything you want i don't
think that's the
rule it is stupid
uh mini driver has a beautiful singing
voice as well segway oh my god what an
amazing oh my god i know i did sing like
two bars with a song and i like melted
in my chair like i you know it's crazy i
like have just vague memories of her
being
like being struck by that when we were
doing karaoke amazing amazing i know i
hear her albums now me too yeah me too
you don't both will have to want to hear
many drivers
a little bit um oh by the way why is she
called minnie that's well you should get
her on the show and ask her because
that's a really good question my god i
can't believe it and it was one of your
questions that you failed oh my god ask
her oh my god aren't you curious yes
because her real name is something else
her birth name amelia i think i think
you're right because i saw it on her
zoom today maybe it was just like a
nickname qpf name i'm hoping that that's
what it is because i hope there's not a
really good story attached i can't
believe i forgot to ask that i was
looking at those questions i was like oh
i can't wait to ask this also i love the
name amelia we talk about him like
but amelia rogers yeah four syllables
you know how i feel about long syllable
names you know both have multiple
multiples both like multi-syllable names
because they take unnecessarily long
time to say
hey let's read a letter okay
that wasn't the chair i know
let's see if miesha keeps that in i hope
she does yeah
this is from
jillian f halter
subject hey j austin and chris christian
oh that's funny like the brickish yes
yeah jay apostrophe usd that's funny hey
you guys i love your show i immediately
like this person yeah i do too you know
um because she said she likes your show
partly probably but also the subject is
really funny austin and craig
um i love you i've been listening to the
more recent ones before going back to
the beginning and i just heard that rc
card an episode today okay that's right
that's it that's funny darcy carlin
because darcy spells d apostrophe
a-r-c-y
uh and she has three hearts eye emojis
and she says we need a heart ears emoji
ah yeah that's a good point hearties it
might be kind of tough to do and people
will be like what is that carpet but you
know what you do it's not an expression
yeah yeah yeah that's true um but you
could do it the ear well neither is hard
eyes i guess no but like when you look
it's a more common that's true in like
cartoons
yeah
uh but you could do like ear and heart
whatever speaking of ear back to chilean
speaking of years justin you mentioned
being interested in learning american
sign language and i'm here to encourage
you to take a class
okay so christian you don't both have to
want to learn american sign language
that's so funny because i
like two days ago i found
a book i've had since i was in
kindergarten and kindergarten
kindergarten
and it was the uh it's the american sign
language dictionary i guess and
it was gifted to me
by my kindergarten teacher
shout out mrs swalin
and inscribed in it was something
defective
uh dear christian
i hope you never stop pursuing your goal
of learning sign language and it
reminded me that when i was in
kindergarten i got really into trying to
learn sign language i knew the whole
alphabet
and i started to learn it and now
i'm now inspired after having seen that
inscription to get back into it and
learn it properly wow i love i think
it's so beautiful it's so expressive i
know it's so cool and i want to now give
a shout out to my kindergarten teacher
miss humphrey
what did she give you um
other than a education you know she
helped me when i pooped my pants and
she was very tender and gentle and like
sent me off to the nurse when i pooped
and um as i thought it was a half day
and
it was a full day and so i had a fear of
uh going number two in the bathroom so i
did in my over at my eyes and that never
changed
no that's true i still have
yeah i like my space um
anyway
okay back to the letter
and uh back to the letter let back to
jillian sorry for that detour gameesha
has a lot of uh decisions to make i hope
she leaves it all in me too okay like
you i find it fascinating and i was
inspired to sign up for asl uh one last
may after seeing some incredible missy
elliott's song interpretations on
instagram cool
it'd be fun to do i can't stand the rain
i was just thinking yeah i can't stand
the rain
oh boy do you wish i just thought it
like no i'm glad you said that because
it's uh
it made me smile
you do that okay cover slash cringe uh i
fell in love with it on the first night
and a year later i've completed five
eight week courses good for you jillian
at this point that wasn't in her letter
she wasn't
referencing the first place that's me
back to jillian at this point i can
carry on a conversation in an asl and
i've learned so much about deaf culture
i've had a few chances to practice in
the wild and it really quotes and it
really means a lot to be able to
communicate with someone in their native
language it does the two
it's
such a sign of respect you know uh
that's why i wanna i'm trying to learn
spanish it's not going too well so
anyway i say do it it's never too late
and you'll have tons of fun and if you
need another reason it'll look good on
your acting resume right do people as
famous as you even need resumes um
no you just go in your hot air balloon
and drop into whatever set you want and
demand a roll
do you know who i am
uh i was in herbie god damn it
anyway lastly and awkwardly i just have
to say my most quoted line from
dodgeball is definitely ready and super
psyched which is your line in case you
don't remember every line you ever said
um i do remember that line and i think
it was scripted you know am i wrong in
saying that you may have
borrowed
that oh maybe from the cheerleader
characters on snl will ferrell and um oh
no no no i def i definitely didn't
rossen the writer director ross and
thurber may have oh really ready and
super psyched i i'm pretty sure that was
scripted i don't know so much that movie
was
not so much of it was improvised but uh
yeah anyway uh julian says okay sorry
for rambling well i am too i feel you
jillian um thank you both for filling my
ears with delight and then i emoji with
the with the hearts all around i look
forward to hearing about your asl
experience emoji with the smiling in
their hands up uh and then this kind of
shock economic with [ __ ] not chaka khan
three of them jill f halter columbus
ohio what a thank you great letter yeah
great and
encouraging i want to
do that let's see who can learn sign
language first i was going to say be fun
to do it on the podcast but it would
actually be a it would be so fun it's
like that seinfeld episode when they're
at the party and they remember oh my god
yes
yeah the lip reader it'd be fun to read
lips too i've gotten pretty good at
reading lips actually people i'm
kind of talking
about that sounds very paranoid
people talking about you yeah
yeah yes it does um
um well thanks for that letter and if
you guys would like to write in
and be the next jillian off halter
our email address is life is short at
wondery.com and i want to thank uh they
have the melodiously voiced melodiously
mellifluous yes and she also what a
vocabulary i
very impressive human being yes great
actress and has a great new podcast
that you should all listen to yes
especially the episode i was on that's
right it's called mini questions yeah
she's so good at it i'm glad she's doing
it and um i was really so fun to catch
up with it more than catch up like
really get to know her and right now you
get to hear the uh closing credits
that's always fun oh man i can't wait i
can't wait to do it i'm going to launch
right into it first of all i'm going to
just want to thank everyone for
listening okay see you next week
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
uh life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted by you christian
long who also produces alongside the
likes of megan v monaco and the senior
producer michelle miesh lans the audio
engineer today is and every day is
sergio enriquez and speaking of every
day this guy makes the most out of his
days with his lovely
lovely family he's the executive
producer marshall louis all of us do it
for a very generous company called
wandery
bye i hope you had fun duri
so
my given name is actually
amelia
when my mum brought me home from the
hospital my two-year-old sister couldn't
say emilia
and so she called me minnie
and then i guess
everybody else in my family decided to
ignore the name i've been given
and
follow the lead of the two-year-old
and that's
how many stuck
you